Sammy what an episode what a game you
played might I add um how are you
feeling now that it's been shown the
dust has settled everything's played out
how are you feeling
you're not so good I'm really grateful
for the experience and uh just so
grateful that I got to do with such
amazing people and you know
I am just really excited to see how it
plays out you know I'm just I'm very
excited to see what happens uh for the
rest of the season and I'm I'm just I'm
just grateful overall really you know I
I'm also at the same time you know I
remember out there I was like okay my
dad's gonna get the Tesla Model why I'm
gonna do the Tesla Model X I'm gonna get
a cyber truck
didn't work out
well I like the positive attitude that's
all all that you can do now so it
matters right
exactly so last night's immunity
challenge was a Survivor classic I have
to ask you before we get into any game
just like what was that like I was I had
a lot of anxiety watching it
um but like what's going through your
head while you're doing that challenge
uh
you know I want to start off by saying I
wouldn't you know I did the challenge
but I don't know if I really like
participated you did I did it was hard
that's how you would go through my mind
was like every single panic I said in I
don't I don't I learned how to swim a
week before I went on survived right a
week before I went out that's where I
learned how to swim and so to do this
like waterboarding like drowning
simulator that you know I remember I I
was saying last night I was like
I don't know if I could do that with my
life on the line let alone a million
dollars like I don't think I could do
that that's fair honestly I don't think
I could do it either so and I was just
watching it I've never experienced it
and I I can't even imagine so of course
you for even doing it okay I just don't
want to get in your eyes your nose your
throat it's cold
ah and I was in I was on like what green
like I my color was off like if I was an
orange I would last a little bit longer
so I also want to talk about the
scramble that was the on the beach when
you guys found out that there was a
hidden advantage in the jungle it was so
fun to watch
um as a big Survivor fan and everyone
kept walking by it I was so shocked
I was so I was too like I think you
walked by it so many times gabler walked
by it so many times like was it
I feel like it was right there in front
of everyone obviously but no one could
see it like how long were you guys out
there looking for it oh it was over an
hour which is the most humiliating part
about it and you know yes we were
definitely blind definitely blind like I
don't know how I didn't see that thing
like I I I I just can't believe it
made me feel better that other people
didn't see it
um
man I think it was camouflage like I
would have never thought that it was on
the trip I was excited to see where it
was until I saw where it was then I was
like man oh that close to being safe
that day like
I don't know about that and speaking of
that Advantage so you guys found out
that Cody may or may not have immunity
depending on who he picked did your
strategy change at all when you found
out that information
yeah so Cody was safe
you know yeah at that point once Cody
found the advantage Cody was safe and
the problem with it was that um I was
looking for anybody but I'll turn full
standard mode at one point like anybody
but me
anybody but me please like yeah please
and um
had Cody come up that day I think he was
writing that name down and you know I
but that's the thing is like it's like
his Threat Level was already kind of
he's so good at diminishing it it was
already kind of down here and by the
time he found the advantages like all
right it's over
yeah that's fair now but it seemed as
though before going to tribal that you
and had Carla like she was buying what
you were selling at least that's what it
appeared to us as viewers
yeah she was willing to or at least it
appeared to vote out her closest Ally so
what do you think changed her mind or
was there something that we didn't see
that maybe flipped a switch on for her
there was already some cracks within
Carla and cass's uh Alliance and I knew
that because Cass and I had discussed
voting out parlor before
um and so when she said he was the first
person to write my name down you know
I knew if I said Jesse which would have
been you know obviously if I could have
got her to slip on Jessie it would have
been great but I remember if I said
Jesse she wouldn't believe me I know so
I said Cody she wouldn't believe me
um so I was like let me like let's see
if it works with cash because there's
these cracks there there's cracks within
their Alliance and um
I was shocked that it worked I really
was and in that moment
I didn't real I didn't really know how
well it did until we got back from the
immunity challenge yeah and then you
know we were all celebrating even tasks
obviously you know rightfully so
disappointed for being in it for so long
and coming up with just a little bit
short when she went off that's when
Carla was like I don't know I'm not
feeling good about her right now like I
don't feel good and I was like
I tried to make it a point to not drag
Cass at that point I try to make it a
point to not you know be like oh yeah
let's do let's prove I was I I felt like
it was smarter to be like listen you
tell me I'm here for you like I'm your
vote yeah absolutely now when you went
to tribal and you announced that you
were going to be playing your shot in
the dark I love the Bold move was there
was that like part of your strategy were
you hoping that saying you're gonna play
your shot in the dark would maybe steer
people away from voting for you or what
was your thought process behind that I
wasn't gonna play it you know I wasn't
gonna play I was gonna go with the votes
that everybody told me to do
um and it was that tribal and I was
trying to talk to Cody and Gaylord kind
of get a little bit of confirmation get
a little bit of uh you know get
something from them and they were giving
me
thing like I don't even look and for
Cody I got it you know but for gabler
that was uncharacteristic very
uncharactalistic and
you know tribal has been really you know
guarded people are guarded at tribal and
nobody really wants to do anything say
anything uh crazy and for me I was like
I can't do that man like I just like I
need to figure something out here and so
then I was looking at uh I was looking
at gabler trying to like like dude
what's going on and then Jeff said Sammy
I was like
um and he said shot in the dark and
that's when I was like
dude I'm playing myself in the dark like
yeah I'm playing it I'm playing it and
and from the moment I said I was playing
it on
um I had the full intention of playing
it and was
still just hoping just a little in the
back of my mind that people were going
to go with what they told me was gonna
happen
I was really hoping that it was gonna
say you're safe because then I knew I
was like oh there's going to be even
more chaos at tribal but a lot we are I
will tell you right now that yes if that
thing comes up safe
you're going to see one of the most
chaotic end games that you would have
seen I would have caused so much trouble
back there
but it's the game you know that's the
game it is what it is it is what it is
but I like the positivity like I told
you and now we're still we're still
gonna see you you're on the jury doesn't
mean you're gone
um it's planned out too
there you go
um but what's it like being on the jury
side of it now like you're you still
have kind of a game to play in a sense
but what's it like being on the jury
is a huge responsibility because you as
somebody that played the game and
understands the game now have to vote
for somebody at the end of this game to
win the game and you know it's it's it
was a lot of fun to kind of reconnect
with the people that were
back with you know Noel and James and
Ryan and Janine that was a lot of fun to
do that with them and uh human setting
you know not in a game setting and um
it's gonna be exciting to see how this
police chase out I don't I don't know
what's gonna happen I am excited I'm a
huge Survivor fan so I'm always looking
forward to Wednesday nights it's my
favorite night of the week
um and lastly I know you've talked about
how your journey obviously didn't play
out the way you wanted it to but how
would you say overall your whole
experience on Survivor was
it was more than I could have ever
imagined you know it was it was had
enough you had the Downs it had the
in-betweens like I have so much respect
and so much love not only for the people
that uh put every you know the for the
people that
early mornings late nights to put
everything into the show just to give us
this kind of an experience that's
transformative and then put it back on
television for us to watch with our
families
um you know to have that moment with my
mom yesterday uh about the letter like
I don't really know how to say thank you
other than to just
I have no words like I'm speechless
almost about how grateful I am for this
entire experience and it was um it was
one that I'll never forget and it and I
come out of it with
some amazing people some great
circumstances and uh
it was great
that's amazing I love to hear that I
love it so much well thank you so much
for your time today and we're still
gonna see you on the jury so you're not
gone yet
um but yeah thank you so much not yet
thank you